how's it going everyone my name is
Pierre ba and the reason why I haven't
been uploading videos is because I'm in
Italy with my girl and I'm having a
great time so you should be happy for me
and I'll promise I'll be back soon and
tomorrow at Sunday at 6 6 p.m. CST I
will be interviewed by a radio station
called no Nord astral radio it's a
pretty big thing for me so if you would
like to join I'd really appreciate it
and I think it will be a lot of fun
you'll be able to ask me questions live
and I'll answer them um I'm also going
to talk to the guy who interviews me
he's been working with the radio for
like 15 years he also has a YouTube page
and you should check him out as well and
yeah that's pretty much it
haha